Most of my life I've had dry skin on my hands if I didn't use lotion often enough
I would have stabbing pain in addition to the dryness
Now I have itchy dry skin with stabbing pain all over my body that has been torturing me for three months
In a telephone conversation about a month ago. I think you mentioned that itchy was common with lymphobiles
I don't want to take the pharmaceutical medications to trade it. I've tried multiple lotions and natural remedies
100% coconut oil is the only thing that brings some relief when applied, but it doesn't do enough
I paid this comfort is constantly a six out of 10 and goes as high as 9 out of 10
In my worst moments when my body temperature changes
Do you know of anything safe for my body that could help my pain?
Also the flavor of the food is not the same as the aroma I'm smelling
This seems so strange to me. I'm taking at least 50 micrograms of zinc daily
For weeks without noticing any improvement. I'm any thoughts on how to remedy this
Well, there's a couple possibilities that are going on with this flavor and the food thing
But I have to do a little bit more investigation to answer that question
As far as the itchiness and the dry skin that you've had most of your life
I'm sure if you already were prone to that for reasons that I'll have to think about for a few minutes here
And then you end up with the phobia on top of that which
Quite often can cause that
It's it's an
exasperated
The symptoms that even most lymphoma patients would have
I'm sorry for that as far as
Dealing with the original
Now the person just calls that I just have dry skin. What can you do about it?
It's really an internal problem
It's not an external problem. It is not you know, yes, that can be caused from external things
Let's say you're using you're using chemicals on your skin because you wash parts in a part clear because you're a mechanic or something
And you don't use gloves and you're getting chemicals and damaging your skin and that's what's causing dry skin
But when you have dry skin
typically without any
You know exposure to
Exogenous sources of that that would damage your skin and your your their external epithelial cells
You think of internal things. So it had quite often has to do with
an inability to break down
fatty acids
If that's covered
More covered than you think that has to do with issues with
Dermatitis and stuff like that too. They have a lack of ability to break down fatty acids and fatty acids are necessary to lubricate
your your dermis layers
so
Doing things topically can be helpful as far as
Like what you're saying you're using you're using coconut oil. I would also think of some
Learn-based creams that might be helpful for you, but you do want to address it internally like increasing
trying
You know a high DHA EPA
You know trying some good different variety of fish oil supplements. I would try that as well
So I have to think about this a little bit. I want to have a conversation about this